danger to Manchester City tomorrow
well I guess that uh
the the biggest mistake we can we can
make
is to forget that this is the final
and people can say whatever they want
but in my mind in our mind
there are no favorites in this game it's
a final and the final will always be a
final no matter what you've done uh to
to reach to reach it to get to here uh
when you when you actually are here you
can only start to be a favorite when you
when you get into the beach and you
start doing things
just in the middle here please in the
red
thank you
for one football I would like to ask you
because the only team who has been able
to beat Manchester City decision has
been Branford which is one of the few
teams in the Premier League who plays
with two Strikers and tomorrow you will
face the same kind of opponent with two
Strikers in front how do you think that
can impact to the strategy for
Manchester City and if it's going to be
different for you as a Defender thank
you
uh uh well there are there are lots of
of games in in a season uh and uh it's
it's difficult to to make that easy
comparison you're making uh at least in
our minds uh it's just another game for
us
um obviously a special one and uh we'll
we'll do everything we can to be ready
for it
they're on the right place
uh my name is
we have seen uh Manchester City with Pep
Guardiola for a lot of years what is the
difference of this year and how
Manchester City playing now
well I guess the every year is different
uh every new some players get out new
players come in and uh every year we we
have to our our biggest fight and our
managers fight and Club wise the the
biggest fight we have is to find the
balance between what we've got for That
season and I think we can all definitely
agree that this season we've we found a
special a special balance to be fair uh
since I've came with we've always uh so
since since I've been here I've always
have felt that we we had built uh
a very very very good uh and balanced
and strong team and uh in the end what
makes the the biggest difference is what
uh what you reach in the end we've
obviously
um got two cups for now and uh we we're
going for for the last for the last one
uh do everything we can to to reach it
but in the end like I said in the
beginning I don't think it's even fair
to compare uh differences because
because every uh football changes uh
players change so we just need to try
and be the best version we can every
every new year
Mike
hi everyone BBC Manchester it's Mike um
line up in that tunnel tomorrow
how will you personally feel will it be
nerves will it be excitement will
knowing the size of the game for the
club and what it could mean not only for
the the trophy itself but but also the
treble that's at stake too
well I think uh I've been saying this
for a long time uh not not just now uh
in these final moments in in which
everything gets decided but since since
a long time
um when we got to these I don't know I
would say since February March uh when
the decisions come up it's The Sweet
Spot and um you can see the character of
a team when you when you arrive to these
stages and you can see how much your
team wants to move forward or if you or
if your team just starts hiding and uh I
guess that uh especially since that
moment we've seen we've seen our team
face showing up every time and uh
tomorrow tomorrow will be no different
uh it's another game it's another time
for for all of us to step up to the
occasion and uh all of us want to be
there and want to do it so we'll we'll
be there Pope
hi Reuben on Saturday we saw you giving
a team talk to the players on the pitch
um is that an important part of your
role to motivate the players and will
you be doing the same again tomorrow
well I guess it's an important part of
my role as it is of uh everyone else's
in our team we we've got our group of
five captains but in the end uh all of
us uh kind of uh captains of their own
and all of us can step up when the time
is right uh I think it's uh a very
special characteristic our team has
because in the end and the
the the main the main word goes out to
the club because they were able to to to
get together a group of players that
probably every everyone in in its own uh
past uh context they were all leaders uh
in the in the past context and we've
brought all those leaders together
that's why we when these moments come
and not just the champions league but
also the Premier League also the FA Cup
throughout the years when these moments
come we know when when it's time to step
up and we know when it's time to to have
the uh strength within ourselves so you
you have many voices in the dressing
room not just one not just five and I
think that's a special attribute our
team has
just in the middle place I'll leave on
IC sports high Reuben you said tomorrow
isn't just another game but very special
one considering this could be the
trouble winning game how are you feeling
pressure wise do you think also kind of
in some way hold you back
well we we love the pressure uh since a
long time the pressure has been on and
beloved
um the pressure and it's in the right
measure will make you run faster we'll
make you jump higher we'll make you be
more focused and in the end that's what
these kind of games need you just gotta
embrace it like we do and uh do you
think never forget to be yourself
but mostly we we enjoy we enjoy the
moment and we know we know what it means
to us to to our club to our fans to all
to everyone involved to our families
and uh we we never forget also to to
enjoy it
just at the front here please
and just pass it down please just if you
keep it coming keep it coming
thank you
in Italian or in English
eliano
okay
[Music]
um
I almost understand everything almost
just the final bit I lost you
um well it's a final of the Champions
League uh we couldn't expect an easy job
uh it wouldn't be the final of the
champions league if there was an an easy
job in front of you so uh we know we
know which are the strength of uh of
inter it's not just one two or three
players like you said uh but yes the
whole team and uh we we know that the
moment we don't give them enough
importance we're already making a
mistake and we're not going to do that
mistake
okay thank you guys
yeah
thank you
foreign
yes yeah
no it's okay
[Music]
uh just a reminder to ask you a question
either in Turkish English Spanish or
Italian please
some hands again please guys we'll start
there at the bottom
just with John please
hi Kevin uh John Murray from the BBC
you've been at Manchester City for for
such a long time now and being a part of
it being a part of this this uh you know
attempt to win the champions league and
and now when it's so close what would be
obviously so momentous for the club just
give us a few thoughts and and how
everyone's feeling about it
uh evening
um yeah been here a long time
um
you know it's for me it's been
incredible you know the eight years that
I've been here
um
had lots of uh High moments obviously
we've been competing in this competition
but we've not been able to win it yet
and this is probably the only little
remark that people can give us but
I feel we've been consistent we've been
good in this competition and
yeah we just need to find a way to to
win the first one but yeah if we would
be able to do that that would be
obviously
um immense for the players for the club
um for the fans would obviously be
something amazing
Kosovo uh coaching zagi said that uh
Manchester city is one of the best teams
in Europe
and uh you are the favor is to win
tomorrow uh but what that X Factor has
Manchester City to be one of the best
teams in Europe because you will play 11
versus 11 tomorrow
well thank you to the coach anyway I
think we we work really hard to to
perform at the best we can do and um
you know we've been able to win a lot of
um games and trophies domestically and
um
I think everybody knows in this room how
we play how we set up as a team
offensively and defensively and um you
know we're just gonna try and do the
same tomorrow
like Kevin Simon baikovski Manchester
Evening News
um obviously there are challenges every
season but given the effort and the
disruption of the World Cup in the
middle of the Season how satisfying is
it for
you and the squad that you you sat here
one game from a treble
um
yeah okay the disruption is what it is
it's a little bit weird in a way but
um
and another kind of feeling it's it
wasn't weird at all you know because you
come back from the World Cup and you
just go on with it obviously everybody
has a different feeling towards it
but you know obviously I'm I'm very
proud and happy with what we've achieved
as a team you know it's been amazing
whatever we've done and
um we want to do the next step tomorrow
to make it even more incredible that's
the only thing I can really say you know
we've done
really good as a team and a lot of the
players been been incredible so I'm very
happy
I'm against from the Norwegian newspaper
VG you talked a lot about their
chemistry with erling but was it Love at
First sorry when you met in the summer
no no
I'm I'm I'm happy with my wife
what
um
yeah I think so you know um I I don't
know it's something that I don't really
can explain and sometimes you you have a
feeling with a player and you understand
what he wants and he understands what
what I what I want or what I can do
um
but yeah it just clicked really well and
obviously he started scoring at an
incredible rate and that helps and that
settled them uh really easy in the team
but they've done it the whole year and
even you know in the last games it's
been really important for us in
different ways so um yeah hopefully he
can do what he needs to do tomorrow
Kevin Emiliano Sports Mexico here
a lot of patience tomorrow do you see it
the same way what kind of match do you
imagine
well I think we understand what
interests you know they're very compact
very very good side to play with the
five three two normally you know and
they always play that system under that
coach the two Strikers they hold the
ball up really well and then they have a
lot of Runners from Midfield and
fullback so you know we we understand
what they are as a team and they defend
incredible well
um so we don't expect it to be an open
game I don't think that happens a lot in
the finals anyway so so I think we have
to understand not to get too nervous too
quickly and you know maybe there won't
be a lot of chances in the beginning but
you know we have to try and play the way
that we we do and be comfortable with
um without play in the game and then
hopefully we'll find openings and uh
start to create chances and score some
goals hi Kevin from Hungary I'm here yes
how do you see the Tactical side of the
Intel because they are generally playing
you know three Central back system which
can be a five Defender system in the
defending situations how hard exercise
to the Manchester City to play this kind
of style because this can be a little
unusual
but to be honest I think
um
in the last five six years that I've
played in the Premier League I think uh
a lot of the lower teams are playing
with the five at
um maybe more five four one formation
but they do it with two Strikers what
makes him maybe a little bit more
different uh what we're used to
um but you know I think the the
advantage that inter has at that record
in comparison to two teams in in England
maybe they play this all the time they
know exactly what they do they know
their system in and out the players know
their roles so and they're very good at
it so it's it's obviously going to be
hard
here
what's winning the champions league mean
for city is it a dream or is it an
obsession as someone described it
um
maybe both you know depends who you ask
I think everybody every professional
player wants to win the champions league
and wants to be at the top
with their teams and also individually
so if you can win the Champions League
you've reached one of the biggest things
you can do as a player and um as a team
so
um to be able to compete
um
year in year out and this competition is
amazing because I've I've been able to
compete against the best players in the
world and the best teams and um you know
um tomorrow we've got a chance to to
close that if we if we are good enough
Barcelona
um you were talking before about your
ideas in the club you played the
semi-final against Real Madrid the final
against Chelsea you lost and then that's
the final tomorrow do you feel something
different I mean you and the whole team
this time is that time your time do you
feel something different
that's the question I can answer you
tomorrow you know I don't know
um
you know we lost two years ago it's it
happens you know we didn't we were not
good enough at the day and you have to
accept it you know it kind of cannot
only take the
the good moments in in my career as a
team as a player and say all the bad
moments go away you know you have to
accept it and you're gone but luckily we
have another chance we have another
opportunity to prove that we are able to
to win this competition and we should
take it uh
um in that perspective in my mind
last two please guys Sam hi Kevin Sam
Lee from the athletic it's a similar
question in terms of
the squad and how they were prepared for
the last final the first one you went to
together and this one now does it feel
any different does it feel the same you
know it would be easy for us to say oh
well they learned from the last time now
they'll be better but what does it feel
like inside the squad
I don't feel a lot of difference maybe
um
the difference now is that we had to
play the the the final last week was a
different uh Prospect than we had two
years ago where we had a long two weeks
I think in preparation so maybe that
could be a good thing to play a full 90
minutes in a cup game against United but
in my view how I try to treat myself or
prepare myself for a game I don't want
to do too many things too too different
you know it's it's a more hectic week I
would say with everything that goes on
built for the rest I try to maintain as
as normal as possible last question
please guys yeah
congratulations Kevin for reaching the
final nicosity from live sport newspaper
I would like to ask you from physical
option if I could say that we all
thought that the beginning of the season
last August last September when the
group stages started that it's going to
be a hard season with World Cup in the
middle of it now you have spent a lot of
energy or the double winners and how
how challenging and how you know how
much energy left for you to to play this
final June 10 I mean it's too late for
the season thank you
well I think everybody will have enough
energy for tomorrow
um wow I would say
um from a physical standpoint if you're
fit you can play the whole year long I
would say mentally is more more
difficult than physically because if you
are in a good shape
you can play every three three four days
I would say mentally it's more tiring
because you need sometimes the the rest
um
but I don't see any issue and then
tomorrow you know if in in that kind of
occasion the motivation will be there
the energy will be there from both sides
so um
you know I think after a final maybe
that can change because you know it's
it's basically over the season and then
um you can have a drop off but
yeah no questions in that regard for
myself
thank you guys
continue with the head coach shortly
foreign
okay we'll continue with the head coach
and then we'll go over to the Manchester
-1 training session please raise your
hand and locate the name of your
organization
can we start over here please with James
look at the microphone
there thank you
hi pep James Ducker from The Daily
Telegraph
um Kevin De bruyne has just said when
asked if winning the champions league is
a dream or an obsession for City he said
maybe both what's your view
it's absolutely a dream yeah
absolutely a dream
and you know to achieve to achieve
things or what you have to have for the
you know the correct portion of
obsession you know to desire to want it
when the obsession is a is a positive
word for the fact that we desire and
willing you know to try to do it but of
course a dream for all of us
ciao
Jack Gordon from The Daily Mail
obviously your massive favorites
tomorrow
um which is unusual for a European final
like this how do you go about
keeping the players sort of focused on
them on the job in hand
most every
single game we play during the season
this is a special look this
press conference room how many people
we are here but normally it doesn't
happen that is we know exactly how
important it is the competition but uh
so
I don't control what the people
have an opinion about the type of game
and just focus what you have to do so
why so as much games as possible about
the internet Milan to try to know them
as better as possible and
and try to do our game at the end
everything finishes a football game and
the team who are going to perform better
during 95 minutes they will be the
winners there will be the favorite song
what happened in the past in the season
if you can count about the history in
this competition enter the Milan is
bigger than us
but that is not important it's not
important people say you are favorites
favorite and of favorite this is not
important important tomorrow at 10 pm
Istanbul time
do the best performance as possible that
will make the difference
I'm pet Mike from BBC Radio Manchester
City fans have in the past made their
voices known about this competition
pre-kick off but last week ilki gunduin
spoke of how a positive atmosphere
really helped the side at Wembley in the
FA Cup Final so how important is it that
perhaps City fans replicate that
positive atmosphere tomorrow absolutely
I'm completely agree with Hilton is a
day to celebrate so the interfounds that
Manchester City finds is a day to be
happy to celebrate being here
so this is the most important feeling so
it's it's finished you know to what
happened in the past in the past we're
First Learning champions league and
Welfare is an incredible competition
so they try to organize the best
competition as possible we are here to
support conditionally what ufas doing in
this in this Tournament of course we are
not going to go anymore and we are going
to support support the game and try to
have fun
um
foreign
is
um
have had unexpected goals of 9.6 in the
last 12 game it has it has not been that
low since 2019. do you have an answer
answer on why it's that low right now or
what's your thoughts about it
yeah oh I'm not here to discuss about
the average to the right convert for
airline scoring goals
you will be the lonely person so I don't
have any doubt so
so tomorrow he will be ready to help us
to win the Champions League
from Arabic post uh in case you don't
know you are a source of inspiration for
the Arab youth who are dreaming to be
coaches one day
so I want to ask you what are the main
principles behind your success and
what's your message for every young in
the Arab world who want to take the same
path as you
have a good players
My Success
now this is my success
no I'm not joking huh
is the truth so
uh
let them feel alone they cannot do it
and let them fill that together we are
in a stronger strong team have the same
idea
the guys who follow us or follow me
they will be here the guys who don't try
to do it they will not be here
but every manager had success in the
past and the person will be in the
future for a long time is because having
a strong strong institutions
and especially strong institutions have
an exceptional place so
I would like to tell you whenever the
manager the scorer will never ever
Dave hi pet uh David McDonald from The
Daily Mirror um two years ago you lost
the final to Chelsea what lessons do you
feel you and the players learn from that
defeat that experience that gives you
the confidence there'll be different
outcome tomorrow
I would like to tell you I would like to
tell you
the lessons but I don't know
I don't know because it's different game
is two years later many things happen
different players different competitions
so
but I'm pretty sure the two seasons ago
what we planned what we had in mind is
try to have success to do good game
against Chelsea it didn't work
and that's why
that's why all the people say the
decision was wrong and tomorrow will be
the same I have a plan happening there I
communicate to the players who are going
to apply it they have success that
theirs will be good if it's wrong the
deaths will be bad so
but uh
we are ready at the feeling that we are
ready the players will give absolutely
everything knowing and respecting a lot
to the opponents that we have ahead of
us
could not be otherwise so
and yeah go for it
um
Gambia
is
distinto
UMass
ES
uh
foreign
of course the details are so decisive
you have 90 minutes or just a bit more
to decide the whole thing
what's the balance between following the
plan following the preset rules and
freedom creativity for the players
follow the plan give us stability
the plan helps in the uncertain moments
during the game come back where we are
our plan that give us you know in terms
of security it's important when you play
the final to have exactly what you have
to do doing that will be stable
that game there are moments that became
crazy and they are one game like uh
is going bad or put to try to put more
Strikers and we're going wrong or where
to defend something in the last minutes
where we put seven Central Defenders so
I don't know
and there are a moments that
guys there's no tactics here there's
nothing it's just desire you have to go
but that will be
it depends of the game is going on in
the beginning I don't believe much in
the final say okay
uh do whatever you want because you have
to be stable in a finance you know
defend well and attack a lot of control
they are a master to defend
middle block or deep really really well
and you have to be patient the most
important thing in this type of games is
thinking that we are 0-0
thinking that we are losing and we are
not losing is zero zero
and the Italian teams with zero zero
they are thinking we are winning and
they are not winning is zero zero
and that's why you have to be stable
here and Get Rhythm but in the same
times
be be stable and in the bad moment a
step forward
it's going to happen
so football never know what's going to
happen zero zero or result once you go
down or one zero up
so in both secret senses
you know maybe a silver
first of all good luck for tomorrow and
uh who will be most dangerous player in
inter for you tomorrow
for the way they play
this is
an exceptional keeper to take a decision
to build up really really good
and all the process they do with bastony
in the left side especially is is
exceptional and after the quality they
have to link
with the strikers like they have the
ability to give an extra pass an extra
pass
and uh yeah we have to try to
to defend sometimes I think you know I
don't know how I try to defend the best
as possible disconnections
and especially with the ball to try to
attack always is difficult for our
experience to attack five in the back
three players there in the middle always
have been difficult with struggle in
Premier League every time it happened
but we're going to try tomorrow find a
solution to to be more effective in
creating problems that is the target
thank you guys